هذه ليست طقوسا للتعذيب او العقاب هؤلاء
الشبان المساكين ذنبهم الوحيد انهم وصلوا
الى سن الخامسه والعشرين ولم يتزوجوا بعد
اطلقت اجسادهم بمسحوق القرفه والتوابه ان
لم ترغب بالزواج في الدنمارك فعليك تحمل
العواقب ليست عواقب حياه العزوبيه وحدها
بل الكثير والكثير من مساحيق القرفه
والبهارات التي سيتم القاؤها عليك من قبل
اصدقائك وافراد عائلتك وان كنت سيء الحال
فسيخلطونها ايضا بالماء والبيض لتلتصق على
جسدك
ان استطعت تخطي كل هذه ووصلت الى سن
الثلاثين
فمسحوق الفلفل سيكون بانتظارك على التقليد
الدنماركي الساخر يعود تاريخه لمئات
السنين عندما كان بايع التوابل يستمرون
لفترات طويله كعصب بسبب سفرهم المتكرر
وعدم استقرارهم في مكان واحد والهدف من
هذا التقليد المتوارث وتنبيه العزاب بان
الوقت قد حان ليتزوجوا ما رايكم ان يستحق
البقاء عازبا في الدنمارك كل تلك المجازفه